very happy the next the first of all
thank you can you hear me thank you for
organizing this workshop and this
program and for inviting me I'll talk
about universal sketches and it's a
collaboration with many people as you
can see students my former students will
be with David who is here as well and
some of the students for example Dean
and without seeing all the market or
wheeled on the market zone so please
consider them
alright let me start with question
so this is what I will do I will talk
give some introduction then we'll talk
about some motivation in the area of
software-defined networks and then I'll
present three kinds of Universal
sketches where things probably will not
have time to present all of them but at
least offer a little conclude so let's
start with the question anyone knows
what kind of feature is
yes good it's actually you know what
kind of breed all right so we will come
back to this question let's all right
let's let's let let just me remind you
of what Peter already presented right
which is a streaming model I'll be very
informal this is an insertion on the
model so we observe a sequence of
elements right each element is from some
domain size and frequency of a vector of
a fan of particular number is the number
of times I absorbed sleep really
frequency frequency vector is just a
vector for those frequencies okay and we
have a function from RN to R that you
would like to approximate specifically
what we want is a multiplicative one
perception approximation with some
reasonable probability of success that
we can amplify and what makes this
problem interesting is that we allow
ourselves a single pass over our stream
and sub linear space sub linear bossing
the size of the main and the size of a
beta okay very well and so as we all
know one of the most powerful tools in
this model sketches and so very
informally what is a sketch again if you
have a point in RN and a function that
you want to approximate a sketch is some
sort of dimensionality reduction to
write so we can map our points from RN
to much smaller and you have some
parameters let's say epsilon and the
error parameter Delta is a confidence
parameter and we have some recovery
function that is less interesting that
we can run offline what's interesting is
that in the streaming or in another
models we can compute the sketch and
then basically work only with this
kitchen right so the space instead of
and functional friend will be functional
far which is much smaller and this is as
many applications you know maybe talk
about some of the solutions so this idea
of sketches can be extended in many ways
right and what I want to talk to them
about is one such way which is sketches
for several functions right so if you
have many functions then typically each
such functions requires a separate
sketch a standalone sketch and usually
it is a piece of art right is something
very nice very beautiful and very
complex and which a new function we need
to compute a new sketch if we do it now
evilly if you want to compute
approximations for all those functions
we need a space which is the sum of all
spaces transparent stage 1 stage 2 stage
then of course there is this natural
question could we do something better
can we use a single sketch and somehow
approximate a family of functions not
just one function but many functions are
the same
and then other questions such as can we
do this in the streaming order and of
course can we do it in small space what
is actual space complexity for such
functions so this is a very broad
Universal is somewhat misleading what we
mean Universal family of functions and I
will talk about it but for historical
reasons this is how it was called
originally so this way so let me be a
little bit more precise let's say I have
a family F of functions right and we say
that the sketch is universal sketch for
that particular family if we can recover
so we compute given the point we compute
a sketch of this point and then we can
recover any function from the family
[Music]
okay so and this is also one of the
first questions in the sub linear info
[Music]
this question was asked by Jelani and
it's slightly more different than the
questions that I presented but so this
is a Georgetown model and things but
yeah so all right and so that's a subset
of what people can do in this and as I
said this is not a new question really
right so people ask this question many
forms in venue many different domains
for example the I feel Lunt and tow-rope
and many others consider this similar
question for subset sums in the context
of databases right and the question
there was can use sample how many
samples we need to approximate
while Sam's right and this is a recent
paper by vacuum losses and Lattanzi that
also considers courses for various k k
clustering problems okay and so what I
will do today I will try if I will have
time to talk a few of these papers and I
will start with this which is the
motivation okay so intuitively it is
clear to all of us this is this is an
important theoretical question but turns
out it's also has many practical
applications I'll try to explain talk
about this for the next probably 10
minutes so how many of you have heard
about software-defined networks a few
good so yeah so this is a recent paper a
fairly recent paper is my colleague the
bias seeker and my former students Alan
Gregg and with companies who former
student providers well and the vise
wasn't invited to give a talk about this
resulted stop 2018 and we got funding to
continue this research so let me very
briefly explain very informally what the
software-defined networks on so I guess
my understanding of networks from my
undergrad class or networks was
something like this a network is a graph
that is very robust right so we have
predefined protocols TCP IP UDP is a
very robust and predefined pieces of
hardware right and usually static
foraging and algorithms that we use are
usually optimized for those protocols
and what's important one to so observe
is that usually it's very difficult to
make changes such a robust things that
it is it is usually very difficult to
change anything okay
for reasons that this hardware is just a
black box we can't really look inside
and things like that okay so so so so
this is a standard understanding curve
of how networks work right and until
fairly recently this is how people were
thinking about this but about 10 maybe
15 years ago people came up with this
really simple and transformative idea of
software-defined networks and without
going in too many details the manager is
following it imagine that you control a
segment of a network maybe it's you data
center or cloud or something like that
and because you control everything you
can change everything right and in fact
you do want to change many things right
you you want to be very flexible because
it depends on various problems that you
want addresses a tracer and so they
propose a very simple change rate split
the network into two abstract pieces
right one is a brain or controller
controller knows everything about the
network knows what where you can change
the policy
and it can change all protocols
basically all the way that we can
communicate and the body which is a data
plane which consists from virus routers
or switches that usually pieces of
hardware or even software that a simple
right and optimized for speed very very
fast and this gives you extreme power
right so for example what you can do
when a packet comes through the edge
right to your area right you can change
it to arbitrary reporter call send it in
any way you want you can change the
voyage on the way and then you send it
back okay and this gives us extreme
gives us a very flexible way to deal
with communication and it's allowed to
speed up and be very dynamic and many me
as an asset just give you a few examples
of why this is impactful the market for
fish is projected to be eight billions
by 2021 18t claims by by 2020 seventy
five percent of traffic will be
supported based yeah
and in fact it is already a non-trivial
percentage so a good chance that when
you use your cell phone it's somehow
uses them in some way and Google
proposed something called Jupiter
handles petabytes of data and it's also
based on something that is already very
impactful and will become even more
impactful in the future why I am talking
about this because it's it's important
to understand because this is such a
powerful
here what are the limitations and what
is the requirement and it has many
non-trivial limitations right so a
state-of-the-art barefoot the FINA
switch which is one of the leading
startups in this area can send the 6.5
terabytes of data per second very very
fast and it comes with a price and the
price is a following very small memory
right so maybe megabytes of memory and
very small time it's actually constant
constant time per packet right I only
can spend the few operations there in
each packet so it's really streaming
quality and on top of this the language
they really had to simplify the language
that they use in a very strict way
before the main language for this
this language does not support most data
structures and but at the same time we
as with any other networking environment
we need to answer various questions
written especially important questions
of network monitoring right and those
questions we menu was a familiar with
those questions and these questions of
heavy hitters changes l0 estimations etc
saturated packets ok very well so the
standard way to deal with network
monitoring is and this is what has been
implemented so far is using uniform
sampling so very naive way right let's
call net flow this is what cisco has
implemented and it's a very very simple
way right so we just every packet the
sample the certain probability and I
collect all the sample send them to the
controller and this works very well in
fact it is a universal sketch in some
extent because we can approximate
whatever you want but the guarantees are
not very good right I mean this is also
well known that uniform sampling is not
is not what you want
and then there was a lot of work on
sketches in his domain right many
sketches are known many stations have
been used and let me try now to explain
so let's go back and revisit those
requirements right so as I said the most
difficult requirement here is that the
updating has to be constant right
because of the tongue first because they
cannot really install more than a few
sketches right so if I have to change
later on something right or if I have to
add delete it's becoming more and more
difficult
and so the idea that that we employed
was exactly to use a universal sketch
right and in a very simple way which is
the following right when I absorb a new
packet I've dated some counter in the
sketch and periodically I send just one
sketch and then they can extract
whatever I want from that particular
hopefully motivates why at least in this
scenario we do want to compute something
that is universe and then we had some
experiments and indeed you can see that
as a number of sketches grow we can beat
just a naive application with the same
fixed budget of memory of course ok so
let me now me now very briefly maybe
explain Universal sketches for various
functions and I'll start with what is
known G some functions they will give
very brief intuition for this so what is
the G sub function this is a family of
this form is the sum over all I in my
frequency vector of some function of the
form G of VI vegies increase in this
case the informal theorem states
something like this if G and this is not
precise but just for the sake of
very short explanation if G grows slower
than quadratic then we can approximate
and we can approximate any such function
using a single Universal schedule we try
to explain why how does it work and I
will explain this just for the a very
simple example which is frequency
moments right away P is in the range is
in the range from 1 to 2 K so this LP
norms for P from wanted
and of course it has been already a lot
of work right on this and this is a very
small subset of this work and many
people this room have contributed in
particular stable distributions by puter
can solve this case right frequency
moments fourteen from one to two so what
I want to explain how can we do it with
a single sketch okay so here is a very
simple idea consider two cases case
number one and they have a heavy hitter
what what does it mean that we have a
heavy hitter to have a single element in
now frequency vector that dominates the
rest rate so one element is larger than
the rest
so let's consider this for example of
frequency frequency modes okay
here is a very simple claim that says
something like that if I have FP heavy
element it's also f2 hey why this is the
case well because these two norms are
related in this way right therefore
pretty simple distribution okay what do
we know we know that F to happiness is
easy right we can find F to
heavy-hitters using a mask edge account
sketch on the incline and so this is
exactly the entire idea of this approach
right so if I have FP heavy element I
can invoke an algorithm for f2 heavy
element and I'm guarantee that I will
find also F behavior so doesn't matter
which function I am considering as long
as I have algorithm for two heavy
hitters I also can find FP heavy hitters
more generally G
so that's for the case when I do have a
heavy hitter inside and let's consider
the opposite case when I don't have any
heavy hitters right basically it's no
element dominates and no element can
contribute more than a small fraction
right in this case we can just invoke
some kind of recursive argument
basically sample every element with
certain probabilities probability 1/2
then use the support of your vector by
approximately 1/2 and preserve the 1 so
the whole idea of this universal
sketches for jeezum is the sketch is
just a collection of f2 heavy hitters on
various sub sample levels of Misti the
depth of this recursion is log n so
therefore I only need log n levels of
heavy hitters and such sketch is
completely independent of the function
it's only depends on f2 so therefore it
is universe it's a very simple and
intuitive explanation of what is going
to be a meeting
okay now let me show something a little
bit more complicated and see reversal
sketches for symmetric norms I think
Robbie already presented this result a
few months ago but perhaps still will be
interesting force and I will talk about
universality most so this is a based on
a work with Charles law Isaac Steve
chestnut Robbie Lynn young so what is
the symmetric norm normal symmetric if
it is norm is invariant under coordinate
permutation so it doesn't matter how I
commute my entries as an arm stays the
same and it is environment under side
flips basically it's defined by absolute
values
the various examples of symmetric norms
first of all the LP is symmetric right
top K norm
I just sum up absolute values of top K
elements is symmetric a generalization
of LP which is known as ollege norms are
also symmetric and cetera so this is a
nice norm that
is used in in machine learning and it's
also symmetric so we can support it as
well not every norm is symmetric as you
most matrix norms are not symmetric
for example certain P norm is not
symmetric as long if if P is not equal
to 2 and it's it's easy to see here if
you take a matrix and permute it you can
completely destroy cavity changes so let
me try to explain the result itself and
then I will very briefly explain the
algorithm so consider a sphere in RN
equipped with a hard measure for n
consider a function that is continuous
on the sphere we can define two
quantities one is a supremum of this
field another in the median in terms of
the heart measure the ratio between
these two numbers is what basically what
governs the space complexity of
symmetric norms right so you can think
of it as a ratio between the largest
value and the expected value
almost garceau the exact statement is it
we need to consider this ratio but not
on only on Iran but on all on all RN
primes for and prime smaller than this
well we we can only it is enough to
consider only such prefixes because of
the symmetry because we can basically
permute without changing the known
okay so MMC is a maximum over all such
ratios over all and prime smaller than
our statement says something for the
upper bound we give one pass Universal
algorithm that approximates any such
norm with with the property that MC
squared is bounded by something and uses
MC squared space and the same number is
required
basically this optimum up to par log
factors
and what see yeah I think yes so this
works for all symmetric norms with MMC
less than some value yeah
so more generally if you have a budget
of space right you can compute all
symmetric norms such that MMC is smaller
than this and using one sketch we can
compute simultaneous columns so it's not
even for each it is for also the same
probability uses approximation of
here is an example of these numbers and
how it can side with the known results
for streaming complexity of LP norms
right so for l1 a supremum is square
root of L and median is approximately
square root of n so the MC and MMC as
well is roughly 1 well - of course every
sync is 1 and for L P for P larger than
2 B is 1 and M is approximately n -
that's a very good question
I think we can guarantee some sort of
approximation right if we don't allow
MMC space but less than 1 C space so we
have also result that says a following I
didn't write it carefully that if you
only want up let's say D approximation
then you allow yourself something like
mm C divided by D space so MC divided by
d square something like this so you have
a trade-off immediate so ok and so now
if you square this you see that this is
exactly the space complexity of
streaming Calgary terms for open ok now
let me very briefly try to explain again
without too many details how we can
compute I will I will concentrate on
universality how we get Universal sketch
so the the most critical property that
we will use is monotonicity of symmetric
norms montañesa key means that if I
change if I increase the volume of my
vector
[Music]
finding norm cannot go down so it won't
increase and this follows fairly
straightforwardly from the symmetry let
me try to explain the main idea this
idea I think first appeared in the paper
by David and pewter and use it the idea
is the following
if I take my vector V and I split it in
what we call levels when each entry so
again this is an insertion only although
so I can assume that all coordinates are
negative I split them and two levels
were elements in each level sandwiched
between powers of alpha and I have VI
it's a cardinality of each level so how
many elements and V prime is a modified
reactor way I sort all my coordinates I
I ran them and I sort them according to
their value so far and because the
stream is if you remember the stream is
of size m and H every time we update the
frequency but most one we have at most
something like log M log impossible
right so the first observations that we
can make is that as the norm of this
modified and sorted vector is
approximately the norm of my region why
is that it follows from the monotonicity
and from symmetry right so if I if I
sort it I don't change anything and if I
increase the values by a little bit okay
and more than that this is a little bit
more difficult to prove even if I
approximate each VI so even if I don't
get this exactly but only get it
approximately let's say with 1 plus
minus epsilon then I still get a good
approximation
so now we will work with this modified
reactor V Prime and more than that let's
split it into team reactors right so and
vector let's call the level vector H I
in H I in Level III delete everything a
zero everything except for elements in
in level number I okay now again for the
sacred you will not explain how to get 1
plus epsilon approximation but it's very
easy to understand how we can get let's
say a log M approximation all we need to
do is to approximate norm of the
heaviest level right so let's say one of
the slave of this heaviest without loss
of generality that be the first level
right and from properties of the norm
fairly easy follows that we can sandwich
it by a constant from one side and and
the only thing that is left is to
approximate this heaviest level and this
part I will not explain that you can
show that if you have such heavy level
then similarly to the case with g zom it
implies that v1 not only heavy in L know
in in in my know in our norm but it's
also heavy in l2 sense this level will
be also heavy in L 2 cents and therefore
by invoking image sketches or count
sketches things like that we can also
fairly well approximately 1 does it make
sense and again we absorb the same thing
here we go from arbitrary symmetric norm
to l2 right so it becomes independent of
Norman it only only depends on this
number
I see later on when they want to recover
the actual norm of course I have to
apply different function but just to
construct the sketch all I need to do is
to find various Oklahoma City
and therefore this algorithm is universe
all right so let me have eight minutes I
didn't realize let me go to conclusion
and if they will still have time maybe
I'll show something else so to conclude
we have shown that universal sketches
are useful in various applications we
also discussed algorithms for universal
sketches for symmetric norms and father
families and the many interesting Koplin
problems such as universal sketches for
more general families of knowledge graph
problems etcetera so
so let me go back to this let me maybe
about now the same dog just woke up this
is Shiba Inu it's a famous Japanese dog
and it's famous very cute and happy dog
and one thing that is known about you
buddy know that it's really really hot
dog and half cat so you give you google
it you can find eight ways in which you
buy English more cats and a dog for
example it can climbs on trees and
things like that and lies like to chase
feathers on the string so in our
language it's a universal pet for a
family of all right so let me maybe stop
here thank you so much
[Applause]
so we can understand is that guaranteed
for the see us the same States works for
all that in a certain family with seven
twelve beauty so it's a very good
question I emitted sort of yes for
symmetric norms we have this for old so
I guess what you asking is this for each
over alright
yeah so for symmetric norms we have a
for all which is sort of surprising
because we have an infinite family very
interesting to find I think we could
develop this connection with learning
witches
what are the limitations so do not
extend so are there any natural families
that you know that you can operate
that's a good question I think there is
I don't know but I think for me this is
very difficult
references get some sort of universality
because it's my understanding that the
job there is not I guess I guess we'll
kill this what you're looking for is
like family that individual members can
be scary but no if you want worst case
tonight 82 yeah I would like something
you'll handle but you want something
like Gucci nice but then I mean you have
to make each each known for example you
can recover fairly easy but the entire
thing it is not right this is I think
related to people that didn't have time
to explain
this is something quickly yeah so I
think this is one of the things that we
can talk about so this is a recent paper
with Robbie Invisalign and here we
consider a family that is specified by
set systems I didn't have time to
explain this unfortunately but the ICA
thinks this might answer your question
and let's say a set system that is just
a subset right so each one of those is
easy because it's all 0 right so we can
kind of do it but the collection as a
whole now you want to yes yes so we will
find something that we see dimension the
arrows kind of related if I overshoot in
l2 know they also shoot in like L 17 or
overestimating l2 I made by us the same
way overall
oh you mean can we relate the errors I
don't know I mean I
I think yes but
all right so thanks again
[Applause]